so in terms of the crisis of faith in
terms of your search for truth in terms
of some of the Dark Places you've gone
in your mind uh what's a good answer to
this question
uh so for Camus with Mythic Sisyphus it
was
the question of suicide
is what's the purpose
like what's a good answer to why I keep
going especially when you're struggling
especially when you're not
um
when you're feeling hopeless
when you're feeling like a burden
in this search for Truth where you feel
like you're surrounded by lies what's a
good answer to I live
I think you ever found one well it's
just the simple answer right now is to
say for it's very easy Once you have
kids to say the right answer is you just
of course you brought these kids into
the world
so you have a responsibility that I feel
deeply as a father to them to always be
there for as long as I humanly can and
to take care of them and protect them
it's the most innate
sense in me I'm just you know it's that
it's wired in my animal
my animal existence
so if I take that away right because
that's kind of cheating let's put that
aside because it is cheating it's
cheating they're still you're still
there's still some fundamental way in
which you're alone yeah
and to that
um that that actually has been a real
struggle for me from for many years I
had a real Turning Point early in my
career where
we were flying
somewhere overseas and we're in a really
small plane
and the lights went out and like all
these red lights were flashing and the
plane just started to dive
completely like scariest playing
experience I've ever been in my manager
was next to me who's my brother
he was crying and texting his wife a
goodbye
that's how like crazy this moment was
was a real like genuine genuine like
genuine engine went out playing is going
down Pilots looking like crazy in the
front and it was a really tiny jet
and and like I said my brother next to
me crying typing a text to his wife
really really scary
and I felt nothing I genuinely genuinely
sat there and I was like
this might actually be nice like I I
really felt like
this goes down and like
ah man life sucks is hard and that
sounds so ridiculous I know to say
because I again I like I'm in a
different place now and I see my life
for what it is but at that moment I did
not
so life was primarily defined by
suffering it was a burden and it wasn't
well lifted I was incredibly depressed I
had been on trying different medications
since I was young and I just had not
found anything that was working for me
and then I was in a faith crisis lost
all my faith
um started a band it just became I
wasn't ever thinking that this band I
was like when you call your band Imagine
Dragons you're not thinking that it's
gonna be big okay it was like I was like
this was like a side project that was
fun for me it was like art in college I
was at in school and I was like man I
hate this biology class I'm going to
write down band names like you know what
I mean like it was not hey put
everything aside this is my career let's
go like it just
it happened
and I'm an introvert by Nature it's I'm
really not an extroverted person who
likes to go out and like
I like to be at home with a couple
friends and have a late night
Conversation Over good food like that to
me is a perfect night read a good book
listen to a podcast go on a walk
um you know those are things that I
really really enjoy
and suddenly I'm in this life where I'm
like supposed to be something that I
really don't want to be
except for on stage which is a really
fast like strange thing to me which is
on stage I feel so free and exuberant
and like an extrovert and then I come
off and I just feel like shrivel back
into a shell like it's a it's I I music
does that for me and performing on a
stage does that for me